amen
all right
what do you think is the reason we are
losing members our members and and what
is your solution john 12 well the bible
has a solution i don't have one
john 12
32 and i if i be lifted up from the
earth will draw all men unto me the
first application of that verse is
crucifixion he was lifted up on the
cross it also means lift him up when you
preach lift up truth truth will draw
people to christ in uh the great
controversy page 509 paragraph one ella
white writes
conformity to worldly custom
never convert converts the church to the
world it never converts the world to
christ let me say that again conformity
to worldly custom
converts the church to the world
it never converts the world to christ
when you mingle the things of god with
the secular things you weaken the power
of the message and people drift
are you following me god called the
israelites to be different
and they said to samuel in 1st samuel
chapter 8 make us a king to judge us
like the other nations
when you're called to be different
and you act as though you want to be
like everybody else it is an insult to
god you are desiring a path contrary to
the one for which god brought you into
existence to be different and so we lose
members because we drift from the truth
i was conducting an evangelistic series
in a certain church in canada
and i told them we meet every night for
three weeks and they said every night so
there's little
opposition to that so the pastor said
come and talk to the member so i flew to
the city where it was
and sat down and met with him
uh they gave me all kinds of reasons why
they can't come every night i said to
one when can you come tuesday night well
you come on tuesday night
when can you come wednesday when you
come on wednesday
but i can't shut down the meeting
because you cannot come on this thursday
so we have the meeting
and the past of that meeting told me
to in the third week
of all the meetings they have had in the
past the average attendance at night was
about 30 people
we averaged 160 people
because all i did
was to do what give them thus saith the
lord
that's no joke there's god listening to
me
i was called to do an evangelistic
series in minneapolis
and one night the executive secretary or
ministerial director of the conference
came
and he saw the people
so he asked the local pastor
how do you get 200 people in a church on
a tuesday night
and the pastor said
listen to me
they're all kind of gimmicks churches
use to so-called hold people
holding someone in a church building is
not holding the person in christ
there are two different things
you can hold someone in the building is
the person in christ
only this this
keeps a person in christ
in all my travels i've observed
this attracts old and young
and i get tech so all the time young
people telling me they want to walk with
god god is my witness young people all
the time pastors have sinned i want to
get close to god and i give them this
this
all right next question